[Music]
i know a controversial topic it is
to say the least but i just got to get
it out godzilla vs kong first of all
will not be shown on the 26th of march
it has been pushed back a week to the
31st
but that's okay since we were already
waiting for may to come
and the postponement isn't going to be
such a huge shock except if you're on a
trip to a remote island
where there are no theaters or hbo max
oh wait a minute i don't have hbo max
either
anyway in this video we will discuss as
to why kong will lose the fight against
godzilla
and how it'll play out later after the
fight which means that there might be a
rematch in the future
basically it will be a batman vs
superman but on a gigantic scale
so here it goes okay let us discuss what
happens in the trailer first
of course we saw both of them fighting
at least a part of the fight
and on these clips godzilla didn't even
get to land a single blow on kong
while kong has been shown to punch
godzilla right on the face
he was seen hitting godzilla again and
again and while holding the hammer
he was able to deflect the atomic breath
and then hack it right on the face of
the g-man
this seems a bit too much hype that kong
is having which ultimately means
that he might probably not get a happy
ending i'm split i'm
actually both a kong and godzilla fan
and can't seem to sight with either of
them
like switzerland i'm neutral in the
trailer
godzilla is underestimated and not just
by a bit but by
quite a lot he was seen receiving hits
after hit and not getting to retaliate
all we see is him attacking a naval base
destroying ships and basically creating
havoc wherever he goes
but when facing his equal he wasn't able
to even land a single bite
a tail swipe nor the atomic breath of
course on land comb would have the upper
hand in agility
as we can see him being faster and then
jumping up and down
and like the giant ape that he is he can
move and dodge attacks
but godzilla should have been able to
make mince meat out of the ape
while they were both at sea since that
has its element
and ape no swim but even that didn't
happen so
maybe it was all just to build up
tension for a climax
a final fight elsewhere so
the question is why would kong lose well
this is a tricky question and the answer
might not even be convincing to many of
you all
in the trailer gong was seen transported
away on a big ship
why most probably that skull island was
destroyed and isn't there anymore
if you remember the end credit scenes of
kotm it was said that the titans were
all heading towards the island
and it has recently started to become
unstable and if you think about it
humans cannot trap and hold back gom
against his will
with chains and sedatives unless he was
willing enough to let them do that
it would be the same as holding back
godzilla since they are both equally
powerful
and in the trailer you can actually see
kong looking at the chains with
curiosity and amusement
and he was in fact not hostile at all
anyway kong was seen winning a little
bit too much on the trailer
he first of all gave the g-man the roman
reigns superman punch
later he body slammed him and pushed him
back into the water
he was seen retrieving and holding a
giant battle axe the titan storm breaker
if you will
the next scene after that he was hitting
a home run by using one warbat
as a bat against another warbat as a
ball
then we also saw him going all primal
with a gorilla slam by using both of his
arms and hitting the back of godzilla's
head
then finally he used the battle axe to
deflect and absorb godzilla's atomic
breath
which ended in him driving the axe into
godzilla's face leading to a big white
explosion
this was a little bit too much pr for
kong and a bit too less for godzilla
which leads me to believe that
the end would be way different after all
most of us will not alienate
the other half of the audience the ones
that support godzilla
so why would godzilla win well this is
yet another tricky question as well
first of all godzilla has already had
two wins on the movie screen
and a couple of wins on the comics as
well one would lead to think that
finally he would see his winning streak
n
and that kong would be the brock lesnar
that ends the wrestlemania streak of the
undertaker
which here would be godzilla in the
trailer he was portrayed as a monster
wreaking havoc on the world
attacking military bases and cities and
even monarch
all the madisons had no clue as to why
benevolent protected titan
would suddenly turn over to the dark
side theories are out there that mecha
godzilla was actually the one doing
all this stuff and godzilla is being
framed but i think that godzilla was
actually
him in the trailers and he was sensing
guidora's brain waves and bio-acoustics
from mechagodzilla
and that is why he was in a rampage to
end the evil of godor once and for all
but that will be discussed in depth in
our next video
so going back to the topic at hand
godzilla was now being portrayed as the
bad guy
which in his defense he actually started
that career
in 1954 on that dark road anyway
this seemed a bit too much for a tyrant
that was a protector and one that
actually
saved the humans from the murdos in 2014
and
ending the titans attacks on cities in
the end of kotm in 2019
of course the bad guy has to lose in the
end of the movie
and the good guy will prevail unless
this is avengers infinity war
but wait a minute that too had end game
so why would godzilla win
well maybe because he isn't a bad guy at
all and he was just doing his thing
searching and destroying whatever
remains of the three-headed dragon
which on this universe would be mecha
godzilla the reincarnation of monster
zero
and also that after all the bad pr he
would be revealed again as a force of
good
and would secure at least one win the
ultimate one
but what would really happen these are
all just theories first of all
i'm guessing that skull island goes out
with a big bang or maybe
sings like atlantis and aquaman and kong
has to be transported away to another
place
mechagodzilla is being created and his
bio signature
is detected by godzilla who goes on a
hunting spree
to destroy it and on the way meets kong
and battles in the ship and ocean
while neither of them wins kong somehow
gets to the hollow earth and retrieves
the godzilla killing weapon
the storm breaker and then fights again
in hong kong or maybe tokyo
and in this battle godzilla is nearly
killed but somehow by a tiny margin
turns the tide of the battle in his
favor
and wins but spares kong's life
mechagodzilla then emerges and takes the
advantage of them both
being worn out from the fight to get the
upper hand on the battle with godzilla
kong then realizes the true enemy which
is not godzilla but mechagodzilla
which is actually ghidorah and joins the
belt for the win
in the end gong goes back to isolation
to the hollow earth
as he always likes being alone and
godzilla gets the surface
and the ocean and the rest of the planet
i mean that would be a pretty good
ending neither of the teams lose their
champions and both of them secures a win
godzilla winning the fight and kong
winning an ally
in the end both of them gets to go back
to rule their own domains
which by now we see that kong originally
came from the hollow earth
the one that will fall would be mecha
godzilla but that's just me
i mean i would love to hear a theory
that connects the dots better
and if you have it then put them down in
the comments section
and with that we come to the end of this
video on why gom would lose
our next video will be about what the
battle axe is made of
and what mechagodzilla is made up of so
subscribe
smash that like button for support and
hit that notification bell
for regular updates till then take care
fam